[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
sahtu choisir ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro dédié à vos idées
sorties tout de suite le sommaire de ce
vendredi 9 mars
karaté aïkido ou tajjite sous une
journée pour découvrir les différents
arts martiaux c'est à montigny le
bretonneux ce samedi 10 mars
les associations de la ville vous feront
des démonstrations et des initiations
michel crétins délégué à la vie sportive
sera avec nous pour nous dévoiler le
programme un véritable alchimiste
installé au coeur de chevreuse marque
chenu est artisan siro pied depuis 20
ans il crée des saveurs originales pour
les gourmands et les curieux dans sa
boutique il propose aussi des ateliers
pour découvrir son savoir faire et le
festival électro chic revient pour une
nouvelle édition du 15 au 17 mars
la musique électro à l'honneur à
versailles et des ateliers organisés
pour les plus jeunes apprendre à créer
son morceau et faire la fête entre amis
sans les parents ménez
ok vous semblera riffs de guitares
saturées chant guttural et braydon
amateurs de musique extrêmement rendez
vous ce vendredi et ce samedi à voisins
le bretonneux la salle de la tour
accueille la 7e édition du festival
métal ce faire organisé par
l'association met à soc lui groupes se
partageront la scène durant ces deux
jours en tête d'affiché il y aura du
desk progressif avec gorod ou du death
trash avec bloody alchemy mais aussi des
groupes locaux comme assia le
coordinateur de l'événement était sur le
plateau de cette culture cette semaine
il nous a parlé de cette formation des
scores moderne teinté de james qui a
aussi un petit sous genre mais on peut
dire ça c'est dans le progressif alors
originaire de maurepas là ils répètent
dans nos studios depuis la rentrée et on
avait envie de les accompagner sur cet
événement là
donc en tout cas je pense qu'ils sont
bien motivés sont super contents de
jouer là ils ont la chance aussi de
pouvoir être programmé avec des groupes
justement de têtes d'affiché nationales
en ce que c'est ça aussi le but du métal
cers et de valoriser les groupes local
avec des têtes d'affiché nationales du
14 au 25 mars le festival à tout bout de
champ revient à magny les hameaux 16e
édition de ce rendez vous où se mêlent
humour musique contes expositions
mercredi 14 mars est à 10 heures un
spectacle autour du hip hop et proposer
17 ans hip hop est ce bien sérieux
une conférence dansée ou la chorégraphe
séverine bidon raconte avec humour sa
rencontre avec ce style
ce sera la maison de l'environnement on
regarde tout de suite un extrait de ce
spectacle de danse margie et l'arrivée
[Musique]
il ya 16 ans le hip hop et entraînants
et j
[Musique]
une journée dédiée aux arts martiaux et
aux sports de combat à montigny le
bretonneux ça se passe ce samedi 10 mars
au centre sportif pierre de coubertin
plusieurs plusieurs associations feront
découvrir différents sports comme le
taekwondo le karaté ou l'aïkido avec
nous michel crétins adjoint délégué à la
vie sportive car seat avec la direction
des sports de la ville que cette journée
est proposée
bonjour alors de loin tout l'après midi
vous avez réuni les associations d'arts
martiaux de la ville et j'ai cité
quelques sports mais alors qu'est-ce
qu'on pourra découvrir alors on pourra
découvrir et nous avons sur la ville de
montigny nous avons treize sections
d'arts martiaux donc ce qui est déjà un
bon nombre et en plus ces sections n'ont
pas forcément toutes la possibilité de
se faire connaître se faire voir notre
idée a été de d'organiser une grande un
grand événement qui va permettre aux
gens qui ont soit des adeptes soit des
simples curieux de venir de venir
regarder ce que sont ces différents arts
martiaux et de les découvrir donc de
voir un petit peu les démonstrations de
s'initier et puis on clôturera cette
belle journée par une opa pas dire un
spectacle ce que c'est
ambitieux mais en tout cas une belle
démonstration de tous et toutes ces
grandes sexuation grande représentant l
écran qu est-ce qui aura valeur donc on
a alors devancé dans les différentes
sections donc nous avons des sports de
combat donc il ya des dents dans les
arts martiaux et des sports de combat il
ya des il ya des sections qui sont
beaucoup plus sur la méditation ou sur
la relaxation donc ce qu'est ce que nous
allons essayer de mettre en avant au
cours de cet après midi donc de demain
et parmi les associations il y en a des
plus anciennes d'autres nouvelle venue
l'idée c'est aussi de montrer un petit
peu tout les
tout le panel qui s'offrent aux
habitants tout à fait donc on a des
sections très traditionaliste et puis
d'autres beaucoup plus moderne
je pense notamment à certains sports de
combat comme la boxe qui récemment sont
arrivés récemment parmi les associations
alors on va pas non plus en accepter
parce qu'on commence à avoir beaucoup ça
commence à faire un certain nombre mais
justement l'idée c'était de montrer
toute la diversité de ces deux sections
soit d'arts martiaux soin de soi de
sports de combat et vous l'avez évoqué
mais on peut faire des démonstrations
aussi a donc il est possible de devoir
les démonstrations mais d ici 10
initialement exactement ça sera
accessible à toutes les personnes
qu'elles soient jeunes ou moins jeunes
et leur montrer tout quelles sont les
différences entre les différentes de ses
différentes sections avoir voulu
organiser cette journée c'est la
première et lancions qu'est ce qui vous
a fait sa création alors tout à fait
c'est la première fois que nous
organisons montigny une journée des arts
martiaux en a voulu aussi se faire une
différence par rapport à ce qui se passe
aux alentours puisque souvent on a des
nuit des arts martiaux par exemple mais
qui sont vraiment des choses des
spectacles d'arts martiaux ne s'était
pas du tout l'idée on voulait pas
refaire encore un énième chaud sur le
sur l'agglomération mais beaucoup plus
donc de permettre je vous dis de
découvrir ses différents arts martiaux
leur montrer leur diversité
je veux dire le fait aujourd'hui que
ronde derrière le judo qui est peut être
l'un des plus importants mais il
yad'autres d'autres sections qui sont
aussi dignes d'être connus moins connus
mais pour participer à cette journée il
faut apporter des denrées au profit de
la boutique alimentaire tout à fait donc
l'entrée bien entendu sera libre pour
pour cette journée mais on a souhaité
que les personnes qui puissent se
déplacer ma viennent comme on est
aujourd'hui en plein dans le jeu dire
c'est une je pense là
devoir civique pour les personnes d'aidé
de s'entraider
donc on a pensé qu'il était intéressant
de venir apporter des denrées des
oreilles de basiques qui vont permettre
d'alimenter la banque alimentaire donc
de la ville sachant que voilà sachant
que la banque alimentaire de montigny
est ouvert toute l'année
donc voilà c'est ce même principe que
les restos du coeur
j'étais donc s'amuser tout en faisant
une bonne action c'est exactement
exactement merci beaucoup et c'est un
crétin pour tous ces renseignements sont
n'oubliez pas d'apporter une denrée
alimentaire ou produits d'entretien ou
d'hygiène pour participer à cette
journée dédiée aux arts martiaux
rendez vous samedi 10 mars dès 13h30 et
plus de renseignements sont disponibles
sur le site internet de montigny le
bretonneux merci beaucoup merci on va
parler du coup à présent sapin citronnée
pêche à la framboise ou poivre
pamplemousse voilà quelques exemples de
sirop originaux que vous pouvez trouver
chez l'alchimiste dans son atelier
boutique à chevreux qui fait découvrir
son savoir faire au public
nous sommes allés suivre l'élaboration
de l'une de ses créations
c'est plus long oui comme ça mais vous
avez vous rapprocher plus du véritable
goût de la plante marque chenu est un
amoureux du goût depuis 20 ans il
travaille le produit brut pour en
extraire la véritable saveur et créent
des sirops aujourd'hui siro verveine
gingembre les bouteilles
réapprovisionneront la ferme de gally
chaque détail compte surtout la
température dont 420 effectuons le sucre
déjà le taux de pub à monter et va
s'épaissir
moi si je faisais ça avec
la jambre luxe et du gingembre frais je
vais changer le goût aux gens un peu
caramélisé doucement le goût va changer
ça plus être pareil
moi je veux garder le côté frais du
gingembre la préparation n'ira donc pas
au delà de 70 degrés un véritable
travail d'alchimiste qui lui a valu le
nom de sa boutique ce sirop c'est le
début de son activité le premier d'une
longue série
installé à chevreuse depuis trois ans
marque propose aujourd'hui plus de 70
créations différentes aussi bien des
sureaux avec du poisson fumé du fromage
avec des fromages avec des légumes avec
des viandes donc savoir que le seront
peut être utilisé comme un condiment
comme une sauce c'est ça l'idée
il ya deux ans on a créé avec le
champion de france départ et ç'a un
sirop qu'on appelait velours de tahiti
mais qui est à 0 réalisé que la fleur de
tiaré fraîche et puis récemment il ya eu
un sirop de ses ports aux marins fruités
épicés ou prestigieux une gamme qui se
décline selon les envies marque organise
des ateliers pour faire découvrir son
savoir faire aux curieux et satisfaire
les palais des gourmands l'impératrice
chapelier fou et saint-michel trois
artistes et groupes qui participent au
festival électro chic le festival
électro de versailles de grands parcs
qui a lieu du 15 au 17 mars
des concerts bien sûr sont au programme
mais aussi des ateliers des rendez vous
pour les enfants bonjour mais la nuit au
jour camille non je propose on plonge
dans la programmation donc du shaq du
chic ça c'est le off du festival électro
chic
le premier rendez vous c'est un atelier
le samedi 17 mars le matin de 11h à 12h
vous allez pouvoir découvrir des sites
musicaux pour s'amuser avec les sons les
mélodies les voies et même créer votre
propre tubes aux manettes de l'atelier
le groupe électro-pop saint michel
[Musique]
de paille
paris
m
et comme les adultes ils pourront aussi
profiter de la musique avec une boum une
boum 2 heures pour danser à londres le
théâtre et centre d'art de vélizy
villacoublay
alors là ça débute à 15h ça se termine à
17 heures c'est à vivre entre copains et
copines surtout pas de parents et tout
de suite après un atelier bidouille avec
le circuit blending et pour comprendre
le principe en écoute ludivine ludovic
amouroux
ça fait partie aussi du monde électro
c'est à dire que dans électro il ya
électronique
donc il ya tout un travail ou toute une
réflexion sur sur l'accessoire sur le
doubs vienne le sont parce que c'est des
sondes qui était à la base de voile un
kiki qui sont pas des sons d'instruments
de musique au sens classique mais faire
de la musique avec des accessoires
industriel revisiter des tournées et
c'est l'association data glitch qui
animera cet atelier où vous
transformerez vaut entre vos jouets en
véritable instrument avec un simple fer
à souder et un peu d'imagination
le rendez vous est donné à 17h comme
toujours sur un festival des rendez vous
que nous vous que nous vous donnions ne
sont pas exhaustifs pour ne rien rater
direction le site internet du festival
merci une année on vous verra plutôt à
la bouse atelier alors la boue à la
bourn a wealthy s'amusant merci beaucoup
en tout cas mélanie et avant de nous
quitter je vous propose un dernier
rendez vous à noter dans votre agenda
[Musique]
une nouvelle forme d'improvisation
théâtrale ce samedi au chesnay la lipci
ligue d'improvisation théâtrale du
chesnay inventif vous propose de
découvrir le maestro le public devra
voter pour les plus belles histoires les
plus drôles ou les plus touchantes et
surtout élire en fin de soirée son
comédien préféré le maestro un nouveau
concept à 20h30 au théâtre nouvelle
france le 7 8 loisirs est maintenant
terminé merci de nous avoir suivis nous
espérons que vous avez fait le plein
d'idées sorties pour vous amuser en
famille ou entre amis je vous retrouve
la semaine pour un nouveau numéro je
vous souhaite un excellent week end
[Musique]
où